so I would say I'm like a lip-balm
connoisseur I put some on before we did
this video that's why my lips look so
nice
hey GQ I'm Troy Sivan and these are my
essentials okay so first things first my
ray-bans I hate wearing sunglasses in
general cuz I feel like I don't know
I've just never been able to like pull
them off I don't think but then I
discovered that the smallest just like
classic Wayfarers and not too big of my
face I don't think just does I have a
really tiny face so I have owned like
five pairs of these because I lose them
all the time sit on them oh yeah I just
feel like the classic you kind of can't
go wrong you know what I mean
so these are my like safe sunglasses but
in general I'm really scared of
sunglasses I just feel like I don't grab
douche all the time
next up we have cologne this particular
one is a soft in the scent Marrakesh
I just love fragrances I love candles I
love colognes I love a good perfume like
yeah just a big smell guy I've got a
super sensitive nose I think um Aesop's
an Australian brand they're in the
States though and this one I don't know
it's just like the perfect level of like
if I mentioned a boy wearing this and
like that's really hot if I imagine a
girl wearing this I'm like that's really
hot too it's just like a kind of musky
woody kind of like fire almost I don't
know I'm really into it
so this is my water misting spray bottle
from Amazon I can do a little demo wait
there you go
and basically the reason why I had this
on me a lot of the time is because when
you have curly hair it's a whole big
pallava every time you wet your hair
it's like you have to wait for it to air
dry you have to be really like gentle
with it otherwise it goes frizzy and
stuff and so if you don't feel like
actually going through that entire
process but your hair just kind of feels
flat or like frizzy or whatever you can
use this to do like a light little
refresh of your hair without having to
go through the whole process and it was
like 14 bucks or something like that
love it
Oh hole okay so these ones I'm so
excited about these are packing cubes or
packing bags I am a very messy Packer
and I travel almost all the time so I
needed a solution and this is 100% them
I want a tour right now and instead of
having like a bomb that's exploded in my
suitcase
I have probably like ten of these i
categorized them these are my clean
t-shirts and as I do laundry I just put
everything right where it's like
supposed to be so I've got a dirty
laundry bag that at the end of the day
I'll take off my clothes put them in
there and then when I get them washed I
just put them right back into the little
bags and I'm like never unpacked ten out
of ten for me goodbye I have a deviated
septum
I get sinusitis almost every week and it
sucks and you feel super dry and you've
got like pressure and it's been a lot of
time in hotel rooms and on my tour bus
which is like air-conditioned and you
wake up and you just feel like god-awful
and because I'm so used to getting
sinusitis I know exactly what it feels
like when it first kind of starts and
this stuff it's just like saline mist
like salt and water in a little mist if
you like keep your nasal passages moist
you will not get the same silence at
least I've found so as soon as I start
getting any sort of weirdness this is my
go-to even just on the daily like as I
wake up and I feel really dry this is my
go-to it's an absolute lifesaver
especially when you're on tour and you
can't get sick
so I would say I'm like a lip-balm
connoisseur and I have very chapped lips
like pretty much all the time
and so I've been on the hunt for my
perfect lip balm for as long as I can
remember and I think I found it in this
little Vaseline lip therapy I'm paranoid
about them putting stuff in lip balms
that actually dries out your lips and I
know that people do that and I've had
that happen to me before where I'll like
put a lip balm on and immediately feel
like my lips are in worse condition than
one before I put it on and this I just
feel like it's so pure and has no funny
stuff in it and like no scent or
anything like that it just feels like
standard classic moisture and it's
really thick so you put it on and it
lasts it's like a good few hours I'll
put some on before we did this video
that's why my lips look so nice next up
I can't live without my dog I just got a
dog like maybe two months ago and I
honestly don't know what I did before he
was in my life I'm like absolutely
obsessed with him brings me joy calms me
down makes me get outside more often
makes me not be on my phone so much it's
just an absolute little bundle of joy
and so I constantly have dog treats on
me I feel like a literal dad because
like I'll walk into a hotel and I've got
like toys under my arms little pouches
of peanut butter these guys he loves
them as part of his training I've
decided that like I want to reward him
when he's doing good stuff so I just
like keeping them on me at all times
then if he's just like sitting being
really really chill and sweet at my lap
I can break off a little and give him a
treat and yeah I realized that I sound
like a crazy dog person but it's the
truth
so this one just a shameless plug on my
own merchandise basically look how cute
it is this should be your essential wait
for it oh I bought the blank without the
print on it
goddamnit anyways it's really really
soft and normally just imagine that it
says Troye Sivan world tour on the back
it's really cute you should grab one and
it's actually it's one of my centrioles
cuz it's so so so soft and I'm like a
big comfort guy my mom sleeps with two
of them is like as if they were like a
stuffed animal or something like that so
that should be a testament as to how
lovely and soft it is my next essential
is my mom this is my mom can't live
without her not just saying it because
she is here right now I think he's
saying it because I'm here no I promise
this way obviously I can't live without
you birth to me but I did weird
traveling the world together right now
we certainly are amazing and fun and I'm
a roadie yep we're on tour moms like
obsessed with tour and we get to just
like go into fun stuff and get food and
mum looks after my dog every now and
then it did and dad yeah